the author of the book trumped up how
criminalization of political differences
in dangerous democracy Harvard Law
School professor Alan Dershowitz is with
us professor good to see it thanks for
being back thank you let me go to this
story it's too important and it's an
issue I know you and I have agreed on
over the years most Americans I doubt
know we give the Palestinians money the
Palestinians pay families money of those
who kill Israelis and Americans that is
outrageous waste of taxpayer dollars
thoughts well it's worse than that it
incentivizes murders but I think that
President Trump's decision to recognize
Jerusalem's the capital of Israel is the
perfect response to President Obama's
outrageous orchestration of the Security
Council resolution which he pushed
through as a lame duck that declared the
western wall to be illegally occupied
territory the Hebrew University the
Hadassah Hospital the Jewish quarter
according to this resolution that was
basically pushed through by Obama these
are outrageously flagrant violations of
international law the best response to
that horrible resolution is for the
president to say we don't accept the UN
resolution and the best thing of it is
we're gonna recognize Jerusalem as the
capital of Israel you say it's occupied
we say it's the capital perfect response
agreed let's go to Democratic Senate and
ranking member of the Senate Judiciary
Dianne Feinstein claiming an obstruction
of justice cases forming against the
president you've had very strong
reaction to that is that is it possible
people cite that Nixon they cite they
cite the Clinton affair is there any
obstruction of justice and can you cite
that against a sitting president well
those cases both support my position
that you cannot charge a sitting
president with obstruction of justice if
he simply implements his own
constitutional obligations under article
2 what happened in the Nixon case is
they charge them with obstruction of
justice for telling his subordinates to
lie for destroying evidence of a paying
hush money
in the Clinton case they cited him for
obstruction for telling witnesses to lie
here that there's
is the president committed obstruction
of justice by firing Comey which he had
a perfect right to do Comey said that
himself and if he were to pardon
somebody like Flynn but you cannot hold
the president criminally responsible for
exercising his constitutional authority
remember it's not only the president who
has this kind of immunity senators have
immunity from prosecution judges have
immunity from prosecution if they
perform their constitutionally
appropriate obsessions that's what our
system of checks and balances is all
about let me ask you about this
particular fact you have this guy's
struck then you have I believe somebody
I find his record atrocious Andrew
Weissman and this team that Robert
Muller has put together in the case of
James Comey and this guy struck how can
you possibly be drafting an exoneration
of Hillary Clinton before the
investigation was ever cannot only ever
completed but the key people in the
investigation including Hillary weren't
even interviewed up to that point how is
that possible and does that mean that
needs to be relitigated or
reinvestigated well first of all struck
should have recused himself even if
other people didn't know about his
tweets he knew about them he knew we had
a bias against Trump and in favor of
Clinton he should have recused himself
look I'm against using the criminal
justice system to target political
enemies whether the political enemy is
Hillary Clinton whether the political
enemy is Donald Trump I want to see a
cease fire I want to see us not use the
criminal justice system as a weapon
against our political enemies
I don't think Hillary Clinton should
have been investigated or prosecuted I
don't think Donald Trump should be
investigated and prosecuted I think if
you don't like what a candidate did you
vote against them but you don't try to
create criminal actions whether it be
espionage against Hillary Clinton or
obstruction against Donald Trump manure
3,000 subpoenaed emails or if I had
33,000 subpoenaed emails and I decided
I'm gonna delete them and I decided I'm
gonna acid wash the hard drives that I
decided that that somebody that works
for me is going to bust up the
blackberries I think I would be calling
you and saying
alan dershowitz you may disagree with
some of my politics but i need you to
defend me i don't think any other
american would ever get away with that
isn't that obstruction well you
mentioned the author anderson case in
fact i think that was one of the issues
in that case you have to show a specific
intent to destroy evidence that you know
is under subpoena what often happens is
that companies routinely destroy
documents routinely do think you have to
show a very high level of specific
intent i don't think it was there in the
arthur anderson case i don't think it
was there in the hilary Cole but if you
see I want to make sure we don't
politicize I actually think we've got to
be careful I'm not disagreeing with you
and that's a but if 33,000 emails are
subpoenaed and you delete them and then
not only do you delete them you acid
wash and bleach fit them and then you
destroy the other devices they may be on
that doesn't show intention to you well
you have to demonstrate the chronology
you have to show when they were
destroyed who destroyed them what the
chronology was it's a very very hard
case to make I just think in general we
should not be looking to make criminal
cases against our political opponents we
should leave that to the electoral
process if there are clear unequivocal
cases like the Nixon case then I think
prosecution is appropriate but in
general we should err on the side of
leaving it to the political process
rather than the criminal justice system
professor thank you appreciate you being
with us